hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Lisa
Malik Lisa Malik from good Instagram
we're gonna check out the trailer today
for the secret life of pets alright I
like it already I love pets animated
movie do you me pets no well my roommate
has three cats so ooh I have two maybe
are the cats girls or boys boys I don't
think my cats aren't gay sex sorry Lisa
sorry for the kids watching this trailer
reaction mm-hmm
gay sex is when two men are in love and
it's okay one two three
you okay I'm excited
number luckiest dog in New York because
of her
the same tagline from Toy Story
but with pets
I got big plans I'm gonna sit here and
I'm gonna wait for Katie to come back oh
I miss her so much I have some big news
this is Duke Amer going to be your room
you owe me Chloe
I got a bad situation Katie brought home
a psychopath from the pound I don't even
have a bed now leave it on the floor
like a dog Duke is ruining our lives
Rudy it's an emergency fun god your own
business oh my gosh what happened to you
he's gonna be worried sick we had a
great thing going I blame myself yeah me
too I blame you a lot
one buster both you out of here but you
now want you work for me advantage me oh
just ignore what just happened okay
it's Kevin Hart
my city come find your friend we gotta
take a super grep okay the secret route
was dead
you can find our way home we are
descended from the mighty wolf walk
primal instincts hi how are you there
are moments away Lea's home isn't home
that way seriously the secret life of
dicks is good for litter
Hannibal Buress is in this cool well
Lisa what do you there's a lot going on
in there I know that seem like a lot of
information to handle it I don't know
kids can fully keep up with all that all
those sorta lines right as a adults a
male adult meaning superior brain to the
female brain
well reasons I want to see is because
Louie CK does the voice of the main
character Louie see kids one of my
favorite comedians you know he thought
you know it's gonna be funny
well I don't know because it's because
he's a really like adult comedian yeah
like a lot of vulgarity yeah well you
know so he's a mistress yeah yeah but
he's got a good voice for it
if he could apply some of that like you
know like doggy style like if he can
make fun that like doggy stop cause he's
our dog hahaha that would be funny
hmm honey honey honey honey honey
bunnies apposition funny put up mm-hmm
that's where you uh three it's what two
dogs do that's when the one dog wait
nope okay I should probably cut back a
little bit kids kids tend to watch these
videos it's not ideal when it's an
animated like you said the 11 year olds
er yeah sorry kids you don't get the sex
position joke not today not today that
is the same sighs I'm okay we good - no
no not as a really sad fact one theme I
like that I'm getting from this trailer
is these are like house pets who are put
in a position to try to find their
animal instincts in order to survive
again and that's pretty cool because
I've kind of thought that about like
what if my cats got loose will they be
able to survive I know what I'm like
well what if my cats were just you know
cool cat you have human emotions you
always wonder what your dog's thinking
when it's wagging its tail you know yeah
now you know same time I feel like the
imaginations a little held back you
really because like the big pitch of the
trailer was what like pets do when
you're not around and I really felt like
it doesn't look that crazy what they do
you know and I felt like no like when
they said toys sorry what the toys do
when you're not around
for me when I watch this it kind of
combines what's that movie with um signs
of the lamps no yeah exactly
ah is it forward what are you talking
about that's fair yeah with the hogs in
the one cat it kind of combines a few
storylines I've seen out there already
is a real-life movie or animation not
animation Oh sounds so boring probably
was probably why I can't remember the
name yeah
and it's probably also a classic and I
probably sound dumb that's not for me to
say wait I gotta see what that movie was
really I gotta see what this really
you're gonna take time out of my day
that's gonna look some [ __ ] up Oh
so here it is rude homeward bound
homeward bound
Sassy's shadow yeah exactly homeward
bound it combines homeward bound a
little bit with like finding Nemo choice
story and like that type of film yeah
thanks okay well you can keep her cut
that I just wanted mom you'll see how I
feel when I'm editing this homeward
bound mm-hmm a little bit sorry for me
mean to you mmm that's what happens I
get comfortable people become mean that
really escalated to shut the [ __ ] up I
think this is just the trailer cut I'm
not judging the movie because I haven't
seen the movie but from the trailer cut
it's not giving me something to really
emotionally like latch onto in some way
right you know other than does you know
nostalgia feel of having a pet cuz I
love dogs I really do I'm sure there's
gonna be plenty of moments in here where
I'm like oh look how cute that looks
yeah I flip out when a dog looks so cute
I love dogs yeah a little thought I want
to get a little service look I want to
get a dog that will like you know if I'm
not around can make love to my spouse
darn eight kids total listen to this
video that got crazy
I'm really [ __ ] this up
yeah all right one moment I liked in
this trailer was when he was like trying
to talk to his owner and buddy no-show
that all she can hear was barking yeah
and then it did get me thinking how many
times do i misunderstand my pets you
know what if they're trying to munich
ate something to me and i just got like
the total wrong that's really sad yeah
that's really sad what if they're like
feeling lonely and they want to open up
and i can't be there for them because
i'm like oh you're just happy and you're
cute right alright but daddy's working
right now so let me get back to my [ __ ]
you know i think about that all the time
yeah and it's you never know that i
wonder what the pets are really thinking
dog east uh stuff stitches doggy
stitches that's what they're thinking
let kids have access to youtube listen
guys if you're new to the channel you
know you can do subscribe to the real
rejects become a reject cuz that is a
cool title to name yourself magnesite
he's not even listening he's just
looking what are you reading again we
heard a single thing I just said I think
he's trying to tune it out you wanted me
to stay out of the video no Lisa Malek
is on Instagram Instagram calm / Lisa
and Malik actually her name is Victoria
yeah you're not supposed to know that
great
yeah everyone's gonna be doing just
looking at this video going why didn't
you put Tyrone here from the beginning
now Greg we're gonna be doing another
one yeah whatever I'm sad don't be sad
I'll be back